thank you locals will tell you that
while snow is in a common sight here we
have several winter storms over the past
few years some even bringing snow to the
strip
this was the scene in 2019 some parts of
town seen about eight or nine inches
tonight we're waiting to see if we get
some more snow madison kimbrough there
tonight for more on how people are
taking to the change hi madison
yes brian so it is certainly cold here
but no snow or rain yet that doesn't
mean it won't come later but
earlier it caused quite the stir around
las vegas as people were excited to see
snow flurries in the air
and snow on the ground take a look at
the scene from earlier in
prim near the state line the 15 was
closed in both directions
eventually mid afternoon the roads
cleared up along i-15
and were open again here at the las
vegas sign the weather kept most people
away
but we did find one gentleman from out
of town not expecting these cooler
temperatures in the city i was expecting
it to be
you know mid 60s 70s maybe but yeah
definitely not snow
and freezing like chicago
and as ted's been saying more snow could
fall tonight we'll see what it
looks like out here tomorrow morning and
as we mentioned before
the big snow or the last big snow was in
2019 and before that it was in 2009
and i'll tell you as someone who is new
to the area i didn't realize it gets
this cold all right reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now
surprise madison well